In many ways, life is like one big party.
It is a gathering of energy and a celebration
of existence.
The point of a party is to experience connection,
opportunity, and excitement.
And the point of life itself is to fulfill
these same qualities.
Like a party, life should stimulate an appreciation
of existence and collectivity.
It should make us nervous and excited at the
same time.
It should open us up to new people and new
experiences.
Needless to say, everything we do in life
may not be as fun as a party, but if we approach
everything with the mindset that life is a
continuous effort to celebrate and connect
with life itself, our perspectives and experiences
will begin to change.
Things that would otherwise seem simple or
dull will start to elicit significance and
wonder.
One of our strongest desires is to feel perpetually
intoxicated by the substance of wonder.
To look out the window of our bedroom and
see the same trees, the same street, and the
same grass that we have seen a million times,
yet still feel amazed and inspired as if it
was the first time seeing it.
We want to constantly feel the sensation of
what our infant self felt when stepping into
consciousness for the first time, experiencing
the thrilling mystery of the relationship
between human and nature.
This desire is the reason why people do drugs,
drink alcohol, and party in the first place.
To escape normal life and feel excitement
and stimulation.
But if we view life as a party in itself,
we will constantly feel intoxicated by life’s
wonder, and no longer feel the need to escape
it.
We will no longer have to worry about the
feeling of waking up the morning after a party,
upset that it has ended.